what we're going to do in this video is
think about all of the different ways
that a supply curve or a demand curve
can shift and that's why we actually
have eight versions of the exact same
diagram each of them is showing where we
are right now let's say in a given
region in the ice cream market it's
important to title your grass especially
if you were taking some type of a
standardized exam like an AP exam and in
the vertical axis we have P representing
price and then the horizontal axis Q
representing quantity we have our upward
sloping supply curve
I'm calling this s1 just as kind of our
starting point and then we have our
downward sloping demand curve d1 and
where they intersect that gives us our
equilibrium price p1 and our equilibrium
quantity q1 and once again if you were
taking some type of a standardized test
it's important that you label all of
these things including p1 and q1 and
show this dotted line where two
intersects the horizontal axis is q1 and
where it intersects the vertical axis is
p1 now with that out of the way let's
think about what happens to the
equilibrium price and the equilibrium
quantity given different shifts in the
supply or the demand curve or both of
them so in this first scenario let's
imagine that all of a sudden a major ice
cream producer enters into the market so
here we're going to this first one we're
going to think about a situation where
the supply goes up so one way to think
about it is at any given price people
are willing to supply more quantity so
here we would have our supply curve
shift to the right I'll call this s2
right over here it's shifting to the
right and down and so given this what
happens to our equilibrium price and our
equilibrium quantity
well you see it right over here
if I draw a dotted line we see our
equilibrium price p2 is lower and our
equilibrium quantity Q - Q - is higher
once again assuming that we have a
downward sloping demand curve like this
which is what you would typically see
and so in this case let me just write it
here we have our quantity or actually
let me write it this way we have our
price goes down and our quantity goes up
all right now let's do this example and
let's imagine the other way let's
imagine in this scenario our supply goes
down what is going to happen to this
graph and in particular what's going to
happen to our equilibrium price and our
equilibrium quantity
well in this situation for a given price
people are willing to supply left less
that's how I'd like to think about it so
we would have a shift to the left and up
and so we could call this supply curve 2
right over here and then what is our
equilibrium point it's right over there
it is right over there and so this would
be our new price it has gone up and this
would be our new quantity it has gone
down so price has gone up and quantity
has gone down and once again in either
of these scenarios hopefully this feels
a little bit like common sense if you
have a supplier enter into the market
there's gonna be quantity might go up
and there's more competition and so one
wants the suppliers and so the price
would go down here where the supply goes
down maybe some of the icecream stores
close down
well now the quantity will go down
there's just less people supplying but
the price goes up for the ice-cream
that's there the equilibrium price is
going to be higher now let's do the same
thing with the demand curve let's think
about a situation where first let's
think about a scenario where demand goes
up demand goes up what is going to
happen in what is going to happen in
this world well demand might go up
because maybe there's some type of
report that ice cream is much healthier
for you than expected and so at a given
price people are willing to people are
willing to demand
higher quantity so for example that
prize people would demand a higher
quantity and so we would have a shift to
the right and up let's call this d2
right over here and this is our new
equilibrium point and then notice notice
what has just happened here at our new
equilibrium point this is q2 and then
this right over here is this right over
here is p2 our new price our new
equilibrium price and you equilibrium
quantity in this situation where demand
goes up both price and both price and
quantity are going to go up assuming we
have this upward sloping supply curve
again and once again that makes sense
more people just want to buy ice cream
the total the the supply curve dynamics
have not changed so we're going to move
along that supply curve to the right and
up so both price and quantity go up well
if demand goes down you could imagine
the opposite is going to happen so here
if we have demand goes down let's say a
big study comes out that ice cream is
even unhealthier than we originally
thought well then at a given price
people are going to want they're going
to demand less ice cream and so our
demand curve would shift to the left and
down so we'll call this d2 right over
here and then we can see our equilibrium
price and quantity so let's show that
new equilibrium price is p2 right over
here and that our new equilibrium
quantity is q2 and notice both price and
quantity go down people just don't want
to buy ice cream as much because they
think it's unhealthy now so price goes
down and quantity goes down